This is absolutely fascinating. In the last
24 hours, we learned about a possible plan
for Donald Trump to flee the country to Scotland
either on the day of or the day before Joe Biden's
inauguration. And just as quickly, we learned that
Donald Trump isn't going to be allowed to do that
by Scottish authorities. Now, some of you may know
that Donald Trump has a much beleaguered golf club
in Scotland called Turnberry. And speculation
has been growing over the last day and a half
that Donald Trump was planning to
leave the United States and head there
after Joe Biden's inauguration because of a
high amount of surveillance planes in the area
believed to be sort of laying the groundwork
for Trump to be there for some period of time.
We also are aware of the scheduling of a flight
arrival there on January 19th of a U.S. military
Boeing 757, a plane that Donald Trump sometimes
flies on. And as quickly as that plan came
together, the Scottish First Minister,
Nicola Sturgeon, has blocked the plan,
making it clear that Trump coming
here to play golf during a pandemic.
That's not essential travel and it's not going to
be allowed. He here she is saying it's a no go.
I've no idea what Donald Trump's travel plans
are. And you'll be glad to know. I hope and expect
that as everybody hopes. And it's what everybody
expects. Everybody necessarily will hope that
the travel plan immediately that he has is
there to exit the White House. But beyond that,
I don't I don't know. But it's not you know, we
are not allowing people to come in to Scotland for
an essential purpose right now. And that would
apply to him just as applies to anybody else. And
coming to play golf is not what I would
consider to be an essential purpose.
Isn't that just amazing? And as usual, the
White House initially put out a nondenial. You
you have to read between the lines with all of
the stuff the White House was initially asked,
is Trump planning to leave the country to go to
Scotland on the 19th and 20th? And just dear?
The deputy White House press secretary
said anonymous sources who claim to know
what the president is considering have no idea.
When we have an announcement about January 20th,
we will let you know. So as you can see, nothing
in there. That's a denial. And once it became
clear that Trump wouldn't even be allowed
in Scotland, the White House put out another
carefully worded statement saying the president
has no plans to travel to Scotland on that
date. And again, that may technically be true.
The plan that may have existed would likely now no
longer exist because Trump's been told you can't
come in. But in all seriousness, can you imagine
a funnier headline than former President Trump
denied entry to Scotland? And hilariously, if the
plan was to go there on January 19th, he'd still
be the president. President Trump denied entry
to Scotland is is even funnier. And the truth is,
when the U.S. sends former presidents to Scotland,
they're not sending their best. They're sending a
grifter con man. And Scotland seems to think they
need to shut it down until they can figure out
what the hell is going on. Trump actually might
have to be in the United States during Joe Biden's
inauguration despite his best efforts. And we know
that would be really triggering to Donald Trump.
Someone wrote to me saying, David, he's not really
planning to go to Scotland. Trump is pretending
to be planning to go to Scotland. But he's really
going to go to a country without an extradition
treaty to the United States. The U.S. and Scotland
do have an. Ed. Treaty, for example, Russia
and the U.S. do not China and the U.S. do not,
but I think the idea falls short because Trump
wouldn't be using a military plane to go somewhere
to avoid extradition to the United States. I know
people love talking about Trump fleeing to Russia
or wherever else. I don't actually think Trump's
going to do that. I also believe that Putin is
enough of a troll, that he probably would also say
no to Trump. I don't know. I know that the optics
of a former U.S. president fleeing to Russia
would be really good propagandistic for Russia.
But I also know that Putin is a pretty clever
guy and he may even find it funnier to say no
to Donald Trump. But at the bottom line, this
is all mere speculation. It's really a story
about, once again, Donald Trump's narcissism.
Scotland is closed to travel due to the pandemic,
and Trump may well have the idea that
he can just fly in and play golf.
Two more weeks, my friends, we are
almost there. What will Trump do?
I don't know. We will know in the next two
weeks. Much will be revealed very, very soon.